hey what's up guys my name is the
chernob doing all this
again i was gonna not do that for the
year but it's just who i am
welcome to another one of these one hour
challenge videos where we are going to
do something in
one hour yeah it's the only way i get
anything done is if i set myself a good
timer you know for an hour so as you can
see we are back here in
the office you've probably seen a little
bit of this set before i say set
as if this is like a film set but it's
just it's just my office
and the reason we are here today is
because this is my like desktop computer
this is my primary work environment
and this is all an effort to get you
guys a little bit more involved
with what i do i want to actually start
making more videos of just kind of
day-to-day
programming or work that i end up doing
and kind of
involve you guys more in that so the
fact that there is a camera now set up
behind my computer monitor looking right
at me and my monitors here and my
keyboard is here and all of that stuff
means that hopefully hopefully no
guarantees but maybe just maybe i'll
make
more videos man doing youtube full time
is actually kind of challenging you know
okay so enough talking what are we doing
here today
well i thought it would be a good idea
since the topic of this channel has
somewhat been
bash rendering lately for us to actually
sit down and ride a complete batch
renderer
within an hour just to show that first
of all even though we have a lot of
these videos and they're
kind of they go into details and it's me
kind of talking a lot about how
like why we make decisions and actually
showing you guys how to make everything
step by step
the actual like at the end of the at at
the end of the day the actual
programming part of this is not that
complicated it's definitely possible to
write
a kind of basic batch renderer within an
hour as i'm going to prove here
today and this is going to be kind of
fully featured
so to speak i mean i'm sure that there's
going to be improvements that i'm going
to have to make to it because it's
it's an hour but still at the end of the
day i actually want kind of a working
batch renderer that i can throw any
amount of kind of geometry at it
and it will figure out what to do with
it i want to be able to render
quads of different colors as well as
different textures i basically want to
come out with something that's going to
be usable
by the end of this and that is the plan
for today but first
i want to thank hostinger for sponsoring
this video now hosting i have been a
great sponsor this past month sponsoring
so many videos
and the reason why i love that is
because they're just
good i like hosting her the actual
product that they have is not just
some other product that i'm just
advertising because i want them
no hosting it is actually a product that
i believe in is something that i like to
use because it's just a really easy to
use fully featured web hosting platform
that is extremely affordable as well now
i strongly believe that pretty much
everyone should have a website because a
website it's kind of like your online
presence you can't really control
social media profiles as well as you'd
like i mean you can make a youtube
channel you can make an instagram page
but it's still not going to give you as
much control as if you sit down and make
your own website
you could link all of your social media
there in one place you can have all of
your projects there you can treat it as
a custom blog platform and just
write about whatever it is you want to
write about and at the very least you
can have a professional
place on the internet to actually hold
information about you
which is really important if you're
looking for a job or just looking to
network with people and the reason why
hosting us specifically is such a great
web host is because
their platform is extremely intuitive
and easy to use
apart from the ui just being extremely
clean and simple and easy to use it also
has built-in diagnostics that will help
you diagnose
problems with your actual setup the
other thing that i love about hosting it
is that it's extremely affordable
but it doesn't sacrifice quality to get
there it's not just
a cheap web host cheap in the sense that
it's just
it's not good hosting and manages to
stay affordable whilst also giving me
all the features that i need in a very
well presented package and for
that i honestly cannot find a better
choice of web host so if you guys are
interested in hosting it check the link
in the description below
if you use code churno hosting have been
awesome enough to give you up to 91
off web hosting plans huge thank you
again to hosting it for being such a
lovely sponsor this month
let's get on with this batch rendering
challenge you know secretly these
challenges are actually
extremely helpful i feel that
challenging myself to actually do
something within a time limit
is a really good way to practice both my
programming skills but also i guess my
like thinking skills sitting down and
actually having to work through a
problem
in a finite time is a really good
exercise i think for pretty much
everyone because
the fact that you have that finite time
means that you don't have to put this
off as like oh i don't have time to do
this because it's
i mean you've given yourself a time
limit it's one hour it's not going to
take over your whole evening
or your whole day or sometimes it's
because you know i've done these
challenges in the past obviously i made
a particle system in an hour check out
that video if you haven't already
that that was such a smooth plug i can't
even mention like
a video i've done without being like
check that video out anyway whatever
youtuber live with the particle system
video i knew that i could easily spend a
whole day writing a particle system i
mean
you can definitely take it slow you can
keep adding features you can test it out
with different things you can just play
around with it as
like a sandbox of fun particles
everywhere like you could play with that
stuff
for hours but the fact that i had to do
this within an hour
and i had to send it i had to set a
timer and i had to actually work there
kind of in front of the camera and get
all that all of that stuff done
that i think is just a really cool
experience so the fact that you guys
watching are probably
not youtubers that that doesn't matter
me and you you know we're both people
we're both likely programmers
sit down and try and do this challenge
along with me it doesn't have to be a
batch rendering challenge because you
might not know how to write a batch
renderer and of course that's totally
fine
come up with something that you know
that you most likely can do
maybe even if it's something that you're
not a hundred percent certain you have
the
the necessary skills or experience to
pull off still
sit down and actually try and give
yourself a time limit and work on
something as fast as you can
apart from the fact that you're
basically guaranteed to improve in that
area you'll also have a ton of fun and
likely come out with something that you
can then maybe
improve in the future all right i think
i'm ready my wife and i are planning to
go out for dinner we're going to grab
some dumplings afterwards so that should
be
motivation enough for me to sit down and
get this done
let's do this batch renderer and just
like with the particle system i'm gonna
give you guys a postmortem of how it
went rather than trying to kind of show
me making it because i think this is
gonna be
a lot more useful so what you're seeing
here on screen now is just the result i
want to kind of take you guys through
the code in a minute
live all of this is based on the batch
rendering series that i currently have
going on on my channel
hello mike by the way so if you guys
haven't checked that out and if you want
to know how all this works then i would
really encourage you to check out that
series
there'll be a link up there because
that's going to take you through how
batch rendering works
and how to actually put it together
whereas this is just going to be a
fairly quick overview of how i actually
wrote a complete batch renderer
within an hour so let's check it out so
obviously with this being done like
within an hour and i think it took me
right about an hour i mean to be
completely honest with you guys i didn't
actually end up timing this but
judging by the time like it's five
o'clock now i started at four o'clock
it's it's been an hour i think with me
having done
these challenges now it's really
interesting to reflect and look at the
fact that work
really does kind of expand to fill the
time that you have allocated for it if i
allocated two weeks for a batch renderer
i think it probably would have taken me
two weeks but with this having
like one just having one hour to do this
whole thing
the fact that i had set this arbitrary
time limit for myself and obviously
the fact that i looked at the time every
now and then means that
it took me pretty much exactly an hour i
think that if i had set an hour and a
half it would have taken that long
if i had said 45 minutes i think i think
i could do it in 45 minutes but with
that one hour time limit
it just ended up taking one hour so
that's that's super interesting alright
so we have this kind of scene here
um i like to do this kind of grid uh
thing here it's a little bit difficult
to see all the individual quads that are
being rendered
however there are 6426 different quads
and as you can see in this i'm going
panel
all of that is inside one draw call we
have a variety of colors here
as well as two different textures now
theoretically this system could support
up to
31 textures however i
did not bother loading 31 different
textures especially within an hour
because i feel like that would have
taken like
an hour to set up so i only have this
channel logo and the hazel logo but
that's okay
i think that if anyone wants to test
this out themselves then they can
absolutely do so i believe that it
should work and as always i'll have the
link to the code in the description
below so if you want to download this
code if you want to play around with it
yourself then just check the link in
description below usually i kind of get
these videos out as soon as possible
and then maybe upload the code the next
day so if it's not there make sure you
check back
in the future and just to kind of
demonstrate this actually being dynamic
we also have this quad position that we
can control so we can basically control
the position of this quad it's all in
one batch though
and theoretically like i mean all of
these quads are being resubmitted every
single frame so they are
completely dynamic and making them all
move randomly for example
would be a trivial change now as i
mentioned we do have 6400 quads here
in one draw call because the maximum
quads per draw i've set to be 10
000. now the way that i've written this
renderer as we'll see in a minute means
that i can easily kind of change that i
can just make this
only have a thousand max quad count
which means that only one thousand quads
can be drawn in a single draw call and
if i relaunch this and we take a look at
what that looks like
you can see that now we have seven draws
so we have seven draws making up this
scene it looks the same it still
performs well obviously
but all in all we have seven draw calls
instead of the one that we had when our
limit was
10 000. okay let's dive in and take a
look at the code now i do want to be
quite brief here i'm not going to cover
things like this load texture function
because i think that's
self-explanatory the code base that i
started with by the way is the opengl
based library i've made a video about
that that you can check out
and also download the base library for
yourself and kind of start on that
but essentially what i did was i started
with the base of the last
batch rendering video that i put out now
as of me recording this video
i haven't done the index buffer video
yet so the last video was actually the
dynamic geometry video so that's kind of
the base that i started with and then
from there i mean i had to wipe most of
that clean but i had like for example
the textures already loaded
and i had the shader already loaded but
i had to modify the shader as you'll see
in a minute anyway
so that was kind of the base that i
started off with and then i basically
started by creating this
renderer class here and then just
filling all of that out
so let's start with the design and
architecture of this whole thing first
of all
this is a completely static class
there's absolutely no members whatsoever
here
what i've done is just essentially used
class as like a namespace kind of to
group things together this is just
something that i like doing
it's not a singleton at all because
there is no instance of renderer ever
so don't be fooled into thinking that
that's the case because it's not we have
an init function a shutdown function and
then kind of the meat of the system
behind this which is the begin and
batch and also the flush function and
then this is how we can draw quads the
draw quad function simply takes in
a vector position a vector size and then
a vector color
or a texture id so you can either draw a
flat colored quad or you can draw a
textured
quad we also have some stats here this
is purely for the i am gui
panel that shows how many draws we have
and how many quads we
have that's all it does it's not
actually used by the system
whatsoever okay let's take a look at all
this code
so with it being a static class what
i've done is defined a struct here
called
renderer data now this again could be
any kind of
data structure that you want i mean you
could just have these as variables
inside a namespace you could just have
them as static variables
i like making a little struct called
rendererdata and then making a static
kind of instance of this i mean it's
it's not statically inside a class it's
just static
inside this translation unit meaning
that it's kind of internal to
this translation unit but basically this
is like some static storage that will
contain
all of the data that we actually need
for this renderer up here i've also got
a few constants that basically define
the max squad count the max vertex count
index count and
how many textures we can have now a few
things to note is that
at the moment i've written this as 32
because i know that the platform that
i'm on has
at least 32 texture slots however what
you would probably want to do in a more
serious setting in which you're not
writing this within an hour
is query the driver to find out how many
texture slots you actually have
now i did say earlier that we support 31
textures that's because one of the
textures is reserved
by the renderer for something as we'll
see in the future so
in the renderer data we basically hold
opengl identifiers for things that we
actually need
so these are all the ids for the vertex
array the vertex buffer and the index
buffer
we also have this special white texture
which i will talk about in a minute
index count is how many indices we need
to draw when we actually flush then we
have two
raw pointers here one of which is
basically a pointer a base pointer to
the beginning of the quad buffer which
is a cpu side buffer that contains all
of our vertex data
and then we have this kind of quad
buffer pointer variable which is
basically
where we're up to when we're copying
data into this quad buffer we also have
an array of texture slots here so this
is basically holding which texture slot
maps to what opengl texture id so it's
kind of like a map
i mean it's an it doesn't need to be a
map it's in a it's a stack based array
here
because the key is just the index of
this
array and we'll see that in use in a
minute texture slot index is what index
we can put our next texture into
and then we have some stats here so what
do we do when we initialize the renderer
well the first thing we do is actually
allocate memory
so this quad buffer as i mentioned is
just this raw pointer here which
contains
our cpu side storage for our vertex
buffer so during each frame what we want
to do is basically put data
into that vertex buffer that is on our
cpu side
and so anytime we want to render a quad
we simply copy the
vertex data that we will we create and
copy the vertex data that we want into
this kind of buffer that we hold on the
cpu in c plus plus
and then at the end of that batch we
want to flash that data so what we do is
we copy it
onto our gpu into opengl and then we
execute a draw call so
this kind of quad buffer is our cpu side
storage for all of those vertices now
before some of you get upset with me for
using
new here let me just explain why i'm
using this
so the lifetime of this memory is very
simple
when we start up the renderer using init
we allocate the memory for this quad
buffer
once and then if we go over here in the
shutdown function we
free that memory it's very simple we
have our init and we have our shutdown
the memory is explicitly controlled
by these two functions if you are stupid
and you call init twice in a row for
example
then yes you will probably get a memory
leak amongst other things like
creating extra vertex arrays in opengl
and not deleting the previous ones and
losing references to it anyway basically
you should not call in it twice and a
really easy way to
ensure that you don't is simply to
assert or return or do something
if you notice for example that quad
buffer is not null pointer and you're
calling this because if it's not null
pointer then
well clearly something has said it and
clearly something has called in it
before
anyway the way that we use this quad
buffer is as a pointer to copy memory
into
if it was a smart pointer it would be
quite a hindrance to actually retrieve
the raw pointer from that smart pointer
and then actually copy data into that
memory location it's a lot easier to
deal with this if it's just a raw
pointer as you'll see
throughout this class so to summarize
yes you could technically make this like
a unique pointer or something like that
but it would be a complete hindrance
and also technically speaking you would
have to manually somehow free it or
reset it inside shutdown which kind of
defeats the purpose
so yeah don't hate the raw pointers so
moving on now we create our vertex
arrays which is
fairly straightforward we create a
vertex buffer with the max vertex count
now the vertex itself is a little struct
here that defines what our vertex looks
like
we have a position a color texture
coordinates and a texture
index we set up all the vertex
attributes here so that opengl knows
what our
layout is and of course we don't
actually copy any data to begin with
into this vertex buffer we just mark it
as dynamic and then we do that
every frame next we set up the index
buffer so this is just kind of the
pattern of zero one two two three zero
plus whatever offset we're up to
just a little for loop that will go all
the way up to max index count
to actually fill our index buffer with
our predictable indices and then we of
course
send them to the gpu here and then
finally we have this kind of one by one
white
texture what this is and i actually
talked about this in the game engine
series i think i have a video i'm not
sure what it's called but i'll link it
up there
that will probably explain this a little
bit in a little bit more detail but
essentially what this is is just
literally a
one by one pixel white texture that
essentially acts as no texture at all
and this is good because we can
basically just have a shader with no
branches or anything like that
that can render both a textured quad and
just a flat colored quad because
if we don't want a texture we just use
this texture
which is white meaning that if we
multiply it
with any color it will not affect the
color that we're trying to render
then we set it as texture slot zero so
in other words the first texture the
texture at texas
zero is this white texture then we have
this little
for loop in which we go through all of
our texture slots and just set them to
zero
that's just a little bit of like a mem
clear i could have just used a mem set
honestly
but that's the way that this works now
shutdown deletes everything
except for uh awkwardly does not delete
the um
texture because well i forgot to do that
let's just uh
just shove that under the rug let's not
say anything to me taking more than one
hour to write this renderer please
and that's pretty much all of the
initialization and shutdown code that we
have
okay let's get into how we can use this
renderer well because it kind of was one
hour it's not completely self-contained
we still have a shader that we actually
set
up here and also a whole bunch of
samplers that we set in that shader
because the shader i didn't actually
integrate into the renderer if i had had
more time that is probably something
that i would have done
but this way the client kind of has
control over the exact shader that's
used and all of that
so it does have its benefits but
essentially what we need to do here is
set up a uniform and set all 32 samplers
that we actually have so if we take a
look at the shader quickly
the vertex shader is super simple just
takes in a bunch of vertex attributes
and forwards them
into the fragment shader as well as
setting the gel position to something
that you would expect
and the fragment shader has this uniform
sampler array which has
32 sampler 2ds which are our textures we
then retrieve the index of the texture
that we want to render for this quad or
for this
fragment and then we set our output
color to be that texture we're sampling
from that texture
and multiplying with our vertex color so
the way that this works is pretty simple
if you're rendering a textured chord
color is set to one meaning that you
just multiply the texture
sample with one meaning it does nothing
and then vice versa if you're rendering
a colored quad then this texture is that
one by one white texture
and then you multiply that with the
actual color that you want so thus the
texture lookup does nothing and you're
just
left with your desired color so that's
our quick tour of the shaders moving on
so this is us setting the samplers to
just an ascending value 0 through
31. then we initialize the renderer and
we also shut it down on the detach
function here we load our textures as we
did in that batch rendering
series and then we can scroll down into
on update and actually use this renderer
we reset the stats at the beginning of
the frame and then we begin all this
lovely rendering so begin batch we'll
begin the batch big surprise this is
pretty simple all it does is just reset
this pointer to the beginning so this
pointer keeps track of
where we're currently copying data to in
the cpu side vertex buffer so in other
words if we want to render
another quad in our batch we need to
actually copy all the vertex data
into a specific point in that buffer and
this pointer keeps track of where we're
up to so that we can copy
data into that location at the beginning
of the batch though we
obviously reset this to the beginning of
the buffer because we need to now
overwrite the previous frames data with
our new data
going back into here we have a for loop
that renders all of these colored quads
this is
pretty basic stuff we basically just
call draw quad
now this takes in an x and y position
which is just calculated from this for
loop a
particular size here as well so 0.25 is
the size i could easily make this not
square
or change the size and in fact if i do
something like add a gap here so
i'll make the size slightly smaller than
the spacing between these two quads
and now you should be able to see the
quads a little bit better okay so here
they are these are all of the individual
quads being rendered as you can see
this particular function we're calling
is the color variant let's take a look
at how that works
so the first thing we need to do is
actually check to see if we
have room inside our batch for more
quads because
it's definitely possible that we get to
the point where we have just run out of
vertex buffer because we obviously have
a maximum count up here and if that's
the case if we have actually exhausted
that buffer we just basically need to
reset everything we just need to end the
batch flush what we have now so meaning
render what we have now as a draw and
everything
and then just start a new batch and then
that that's where everything else will
go
so pretty simple stuff now because this
is the color
variant our texture index is simply zero
meaning it's that white texture
because what we did up here is we set
that zero slot to be the white texture
so that's why it's specifically
zero that we set over here in our
texture index gpus like floats that's
why we're using a float here and not an
ant but that's just about the only
reason you could probably get away with
using an n that's fine as well then we
just set up our vertex data so you can
see that we're copying all of this data
right into the quad buffer pointer
because that's pointing to
our next kind of available storage space
for our
quad that we're trying to draw we
calculate and copy the position
color texture coordinates and texture
index for every vertex that makes up
this quad
and then we advance the index count by
six because the quad of course is
six indices we also increment our little
chord count variable here to keep track
of our statistics
and that's pretty much it okay so going
back to our sandbox layer here
that is really it and then we have a
very similar looking
setup here but this renders textures
either the channel text or the hazel
text depending on what iteration our for
loop is up to here
this function is a little bit more
involved because it has to deal with all
of this texture slot stuff
so coming over here into draw quad we
have a similar check here but we also
check to see if we have enough texture
slots to actually render this because
again if we're out of texture slots and
we want to render more than like 31
textures and the reason that it's 31
other textures is because one of them of
course is this white texture so
since we're using that texture slot for
the white texture we have 31
available other texture slots for all of
our textures that we want to render
onto our quads so if we are out of
texture slots then again we just end the
bash flush and begin
again coming over here we do have this
color that is in fact just white because
we're trying to draw a textured quad we
don't want any kind of color now
theoretically of course you could
use this to tint the color of a texture
because if i set this to a value other
than white it will in fact tint it but i
didn't add any kind of api to support
that
so here we have our kind of texture slot
mechanism so what this does
is tries to find if this texture has
already been used
for another quad so in the example that
i showed here
i was obviously reusing textures i was
using the cherno texture many times here
as well as the hazel texture
so clearly we don't need to keep kind of
adding this into
a texture slot and thus kind of taking
up all of our texture slots so what this
for loop does is it iterates through all
of our texture slots and sees if that
texture id of the texture that we're
trying to use is already there because
if it is we can just grab that texture
slot
and we're all good it's already been
added as one of the textures that we
want to
render a chord with now this does kind
of make it a linear complexity you might
want to use something like a hash set
maybe i don't think it's that
necessary though because again there are
like 32 max texture slots
so it's not like you're going to iterate
through a thousand or more elements it's
really quite small
so i don't think that this is a problem
whatsoever finally if you didn't find it
right so if the texture index is still
zero meaning it's that white texture
which means that that's clearly not
valid because you
you probably want to render with your
own texture here so if that index
is zero we simply assign it to the
texture slot index which is the next
available
free texture slot index that is inside
this
array here we then add this texture id
into the texture slots array at that
index and then we increment the index
for the next texture slot then the rest
is business as usual when our copying
texture index instead of of course just
a flat texture index of zero and that's
pretty much it in xcom plus equal six
and
those stats and honestly as you can see
that's all there is to it it's a very
simple batch renderer it does everything
you need it's like 200 lines of code if
we go back into sandbox layer you can
see my usage of this i then simply call
end batch after rendering that kind of
big churno text
whose position is also dynamically
controlled by imgui here
then i just end the batch and then i
just flush it's really as simple as that
i also set up these uniforms but
honestly i don't know why this is here
it probably makes more sense to just put
it
over here after i actually uh enable my
shader here that's kind of it that's the
batch renderer all right so that's
pretty much all there is to it it's
understandably pretty simple it's one of
the things that i love about these one
hour challenges is the fact that
well it's an hour so the stuff you
produce is going to be pretty simple and
thus easy to explain and
hopefully easy for you guys to
understand and kind of learn new things
now i haven't spoken much about the
performance of all of this and i'm aware
of that
it's obviously something that i've just
done in an hour what i want to do in a
future video is actually stress test
this and also talk about some
optimization strategies
let me know in the comment section below
if you want to see something like that
i'll probably work on that sometime next
week or the week after
i also want to mention that if there's
anything that i did not explain
well or if there's something that i just
completely forgot to mention
then please let me know in the comment
section below and i'll try to reply to
you
we can kind of talk about it also if
there are any other one-hour challenges
or just challenges in general that you
would love to see me do then just drop a
comment below
as i mentioned i love doing these and i
absolutely want to do more of this kind
of stuff
in the future but until then i do hope
you guys enjoyed the video if you did
please hit that like button
because that's what keeps me going here
on youtube and also don't forget to
check out hostinger with that link and
code in the description below
and if you'll excuse me i am off to eat
some beautiful dumplings with my
beautiful wife
goodbye
[Music]
you